hey what's up its your boy and Pierce
and I'm here to show you how to pop off
your mic in Chicago is pretty rad when
I'm not spending my time beating up
homeless drifters or murdering Cylons or
controlling the sunset with the motion
of my body wait what what what what the
[ __ ] I like to engage in an activity I
like to call popping off when I use my
sweet hacking skills to grab some sick
air it's as easy as 1 2 3 1 get a car to
find some road blocks 3 crushing amounts
of trial and error
or your camera it's just like learning
how to ollie dudes you just gotta put
the time in practice and then eventually
you'll just be girl
protip trucks are too heavy they do not
pop off cars do cars pop up real good
yeah yeah sometimes if you suck you can
pop off using bridges but that's for
noobs that's not real pumping off get
out of that car if you super pro you can
try popping off on a motorbike that's a
pro pumping off get out of the way lady
pro tips share the love show other
people out of pop off
you know that chick enjoyed poppin off
so much she's off to tell her friends
hey let me fix your car there lady
a word of warning say goodbye to your
reputation poppin off is not popular
with the populace and short gonna murder
a lot of bystanders but it's all just
part of the game son those cars aren't
gonna launch themselves how LC is
supposed to let the common man know that
that but the world it can't hold us down
you just got to pop off every now and
again
tell gravity and physics in and indoor
lighting models that it can be in all
those other games world of watchdogs we
all be just popping off popping off son